une transformation en profondeur le
quartier du val hibou va changer de
visage dans les années à venir un
nouveau projet de rénovation urbaine va
le mener notamment à devenir un éco
quartier
on va essayer de mettre en application
toutes les nouvelles normes et toutes
les nouvelles lois sur justement le
développement vous savez durable sur
l'énergie donc et puis surtout les
espaces verts et débuté en 2005 le
projet se voit doté d'une enveloppe de
65 millions d'euros services sociaux
regroupés création d'un garage solidaire
de liaisons douces et réorganisation du
quartier 56 logements vont être
détruites 600 autres rénovés en même
temps qu'on remet à neuf les logements
notre ambition c'est aussi de repenser
la vie et le fonctionnement du quartier
la circulation en voiture le
stationnement des voitures
l'arrivée de nouveaux équipements
publics des services publics donc mais
aussi pourquoi pas des services
marchands c'est pas seulement comme on
croit des problèmes de sécurité c'est
des problèmes de qualité du bâti de
qualité de la circulation pour pouvoir
venir jusqu'à ce qu'il soit temps qu'il
ment pour pouvoir avoir des endroits où
les enfants jouent dehors au pouvoir
avoir une grande qualité scolaire pour
les enfants
porté par la ville le département la
région ile-de-france et le bailleur les
résidences yvelines essonne
le projet sera pensé avec les habitants
située en plein centre-ville le vélib ou
accueille quatre mille personnes
ça fait une ouverture vers le haut du
quartier baisse l'axé ça sera facile
et un bond des discussions déjà
important pour tout le quartier
notre sécurité la rénovation intérieure
des immeubles doit commencer au début de
l'année 2020 de nouveaux logements en
accession à la propriété doivent aussi
voir le jour
une transformation pensée sur les huit
années à venir